as we reach the end of the year it's
good to take time to look back and
appreciate the fact that that we're
still alive as this year's news articles
have been dominated by stories of gross
incompetence it might be tempting to
think that the world is going backwards
but that's completely not true there's
actually been loads of advances in the
world of science a multitude of space
missions magic lenses new life forms and
3d printed eyeballs we've got a lot of
ground to cover so find a comfortable
seat grab yourself a bowl of champagne
and join me as we look at this year in
science 2018 humanity's inevitable slide
into robot domination continued at a
rampant pace this year it beat us on
reading tests although admittedly some
of us are better than others or that
they can now solve text-based capture
tests in less than 0.05 seconds meaning
that we'll have to jump through even
more hoops to prove that we're not
robots online Boston Dynamics continue
to creep us out with their running and
jumping robots and robots can now cling
to your soft toys to make them come
alive which isn't at all the beginning
of a Stephen King novel
but on a more serious note this year saw
the first recorded fatality caused by a
fully automated system when an uber
self-driving car sadly hit and killed a
woman in Arizona if that wasn't sci-fi
enough for you let's go edit I've DNA
with everyone's favorite gene editing
technique CRISPR CRISPR saw a lot of
development this year which was good bad
and ugly in good news scientists at the
Gladstone Institute discovered a method
for turning skin cells into stem cells
using CRISPR the University of
Pennsylvania announced the first
clinical trials on humans involving the
use of CRISPR to modify the t-cells of
patients to help them fight cancer more
effectively researchers at the
University of Edinburgh used CRISPR to
edit the genome of pigs to make them
resistant to the PRRS virus which
currently costs the pork industry 2.5
billion dollars each year in just Europe
and the US alone
in bad news a report from Stanford
University indicated that CRISPR gene
edits in humans may trigger an immune
response which would severely limit what
it could be used for in humans and a
study in Nature Biotechnology suggests
that the edits that CRISPR makes to your
DNA might not be as accurate as
previously thought
it causes collateral damage including
unintentionally deleting huge chunks of
DNA or rearranging or mutating DNA
sometimes far away from where it was
intended because of this they saw that
15% of the marason human cells they were
studying stopped working clearly there's
still a lot we need to understand about
this new technology which brings us to
the ugly news in November we got the
news from China that the first humans to
be genetically engineered using CRISPR
were born this is worrying on so many
levels essentially these poor children
are being used as human experiments and
it goes against international consensus
about using gene editing techniques on
human embryos I can't believe you've
done this was basically the reaction of
the scientific community when they found
out this news and I mean my view of this
is science is a tool and like any tool
it can be used for good and it can be
used to cause harm and like Uncle Ben
said with great power comes great
responsibility and this is definitely
example where it's being used incredibly
irresponsibly well that was that now
let's have a look at this phone
endlessly amazing that us humans can
just dig some stuff out of the ground
and then put that stuff together in the
right way that it makes a thing that can
launch yourself into space and then go
roam around on other planets like fly
around in space and take photos of
galaxies on the other side of the
universe and there's stuff that came out
of the ground 2018 was a bumper year for
lobbying things into space NASA launched
the transiting exoplanet survey
satellite designed to spot planets
around other stars and it was perfect
timing because the previous telescope
that did this the Kepler space probe
sadly died this year after an amazingly
successful mission over the nine years
that it was running it discovered 2600
planets orbiting distant stars
gave us the fact that about one in five
stars in our galaxy have a planet in the
habitable zone this means that there
might be 50 billion planets with liquid
water on them that we could go and live
on maybe this new satellite is exciting
because it'd be able to see an area 400
times larger than Kepler so NASA are
gonna make tons more discoveries and
rest in peace Kepler you did a great job
in other news the Mars insight
spacecraft launched and successfully
landed on Mars to dig down into the
subsurface to see what's there NASA
approved the Mars helicopter Scout so
there's gonna be a helicopter on Mars in
2020 the spacecraft dawn went silent
after studying the two largest objects
in the asteroid belt Vesta and the dwarf
planet Ceres the Parker's Solar Probe
was launched to study the Sun and solar
wind the Pepe Columbo probe was launched
and will arrive at the planet Mercury in
2025 the Sirus Rex arrived at the
asteroid Bennu it discovered water and
it's going to bring back some asteroid
material back to earth
China's Chung Earth 4 mission launched
to land a robotic craft on the far side
of the Moon and the SpaceX Falcon Heavy
successfully launched a Tesla car into
space despite the fact that there aren't
any roads we didn't just send things
into space we also discovered a load of
stuff in space things like this new
analysis of data from Jupiter's moon
Europa showed evidence of water plumes
this is exciting because if they're
jetting water from underneath the
surface into space we could potentially
send a spacecraft there to look for
signs of life we also saw organic
molecules on Saturn's moon Enceladus we
saw an insanely bright explosion ten to
a hundred times more powerful than a
normal supernova and we called this 80
2018 cow and scientists basically don't
really know what caused it we also don't
know what's causing the repeating fast
radio bursts from an object we've called
FRB one two one one zero two there have
been three hundred of these bursts so
far from the small galaxies three
billion light-years away and they're so
energetic that is estimated that in the
time of an eyeblink the object releases
or energy than the Sun releases in an
entire year astronomers reported the
first detection of matter falling into a
black hole using ESA's xmm-newton
observatory data from the Gaia mission
captured rogue high velocity stars
hurtling towards our galaxy possibly
from another galaxy we saw a super earth
orbiting near the snow line of Barnard's
star just six light-years away from
Earth which might be a good place to go
live in a few billion years and some
people said that we were visited by an
alien spacecraft called umer mohammed
didn't look like a comet or an asteroid
so may have come from outside our solar
system I'm going to interrupt this
program for a quick ad break for my own
things I'm selling some stuffs and
posters some pins and a mug if that
sounds interesting it helps me support
my channel and make more videos like
this check it out on dftba domain of
science and if you're enjoying this
video consider subscribing right onto my
favorite subject of them all physics in
the world of physics researchers at
Harvard reported the first single lens
that can focus all of the colors at the
same time they made a meta material
consisting of arrays of nano structures
to do this this is potentially a huge
deal because it takes what's normally a
stack of lenses and turns it into a
single flat easily made surface and so
it would be good for miniaturizing
lenses and also potentially
revolutionize things like VR and AR
technology researchers found perhaps the
highest temperature superconductor to
date that superconductors are only minus
13 degrees Celsius or 8 degrees
Fahrenheit but only if compressed
between two diamonds to two million
times atmospheric pressure also graphene
was observed to superconductive two
layers are slightly offset from each
other both results are fascinating and
might give us more insight into how to
make other superconducting materials
there was a new record for efficiency
for organic photovoltaic cells bringing
the maximum efficiency up from 15% to
17.3% we
is quite a big jump the most wear
resistant metal so far was created a
platinum gold alloy a hundred times more
durable than high-strength steel the
IceCube neutrino Observatory announced
its first detection of an object in
space tracing back a neutrino to a
blazer a very active center of a distant
galaxy 3.7 billion light years away and
LIGO has made 11 gravitational wave
detection to date Google unveiled its 72
cubic quantum computer physicists
produce a quantum entanglement between
living bacteria and light we found that
the geomagnetic north and south poles of
the earth can flip very fast within 200
years and the standard kilogram was
redefined in terms of Planck's constant
for blimey that was quite the barrage
right onto the world of biology
scientists mapped a complete fruit fly
connect dome at nano scale resolution
from 21 million images showing how all
135 thousand neurons in its brain are
connected the wheat genome was fully
sequenced after 13 years of work which
will help develop strains of wheat that
are resilient to climate change we found
that naked mole-rats don't die of aging
so we can add them to the list of
animals that can't be bothered to die
which includes flatworms and the
immortal jellyfish
we found the largest bird to ever have
existed an extinct elephant bird from
madagascar which was 3 metres tall the
oldest tools outside of Africa were
found in China and dated to 2.1 2
million years ago and an entirely new
form of life was found in a tiny sample
of soil from Nova Scotia called a Hemi
master goat which is not an animal plant
fungus or anything else it's just its
own thing which is an incredible
discovery the earth bio Genome Project
was launched which aims to sequence the
genomes of all 1.5 million animal plant
protozoan and fungal species on earth
over a 10-year period and scientists in
the UK completed the hundred thousand
genomes project which will help
tailoring treatments to specific
patients genetics and brings us to this
year in medicine there are a lot of
advances in the world of medicine this
year and here are some of my top stories
a blood test that can detect eight
common cancer tumors early was developed
in
reported 70% positive results advances
were made in Alzheimer's research where
scientists found that blocking the
enzyme beta secretase in mice and
substantially reduced the formation of
plaques thought to be responsible for
the debilitating disease and 3d printed
corneas were created the FDA approves
the first artificial iris and the first
lab grown lungs were successfully
transplanted into pigs there's a massive
study on the effect of low-dose aspirin
on older healthy people previously
thought to be beneficial but was shown
to actually not be beneficial and
perhaps harmful which is a good thing to
know a new polio vaccine that doesn't
require refrigeration was developed it
can just be freeze-dried which is an
amazing development for transportation
to remote areas and for areas that don't
have refrigeration infrastructure and
finally research was done into the
effects of vaping which is hot amongst
teens with one in five high school is
doing it and the results were not good
at all medical researchers found that
e-cigarettes contain chemicals known to
cause cancer and brain damage as well as
potentially toxic levels of metals
including arsenic chromium lead
manganese and nickel so yeah
smoking got rebranded we've got a whole
new generation of nicotine addicts and
we can look forward to a whole load of
lawsuits happening in about 20 years
well on a lighter note let's look at
this year in climate change okay guys
there's some good news and some bad news
I'll start with the good news
the hole in the ozone layer is
recovering much faster than previously
thought and is now projected to totally
close by the 2030s in the northern
hemisphere in the 2050s in the southern
hemisphere this is a fantastic example
of how humanity can all come together
organize and change their behaviors to
fight a giant existential threat emitted
lee CFC emissions were easier to give up
than carbon emissions but this is still
a great success story that we can use to
show that it's possible for us to enact
large-scale global change which brings
us to the bad news the World
Meteorological Organization published
its latest report showing that co2
levels in the atmosphere reached 405
point 5 parts per million in 2017 this
is up from 403 point 3 in 2016 and 401
parts per million in 2015 there were
record high carbon emissions in 2018 37
point 1 billion metric tons and the
quality of future data will be
negatively affected by the Trump
administration cancelling NASA's carbon
monitoring system because if you can't
see it it doesn't exist the effects of
all of this carbon has been clear the
hottest years on record have been the
last four years west Greenland's ice
sheet is melting at its fastest rate in
centuries which will make sea levels
rise insect populations have crashed
meaning that we're now having to employ
humans to pollinate crops and the IPCC
said things like rapid far-reaching and
unprecedented changes in all aspects of
society are needed to keep global
warming below 1.5 degrees it's hard for
me to work out what to say that hasn't
been said a billion times before we all
know this stuff and it's a toll bomber I
don't know about you but these stories
tend to leave me feeling kind of guilty
and helpless and feeling guilty and
helpless isn't a good place to start
enacting change so I'm starting a new
rule every single climate change story
that talks about how negative everything
is needs to end on one actionable step
that you can take this week to actually
start making progress to fight this
stuff so this is my plan if you think
about every single step of progress is
going to be made by an in
vidual making a decision and so the
trick is to work out how you as an
individual can have the biggest impact
how you can leverage your position to
make the biggest change and I think one
way of doing this is through our
workplaces so if you are a junior
employee you can start a green team if
you're on the management positions you
can help the Green Team or encourage
people to turn off the lights or
computers when they leave work and if
you're a CEO of a company you can really
think about how your company can reduce
its carbon footprint what things it can
do and I know you've got all of those
shareholders banging on about you about
endless profits but what's the point of
endless profits if we're all dead so
let's make the downtown dark whoa well
that just about wraps things up thanks
for coming along from this journey with
me through the science of 2018 and I'm
looking forward to seeing where we go in
2019 so wishing you all a very happy new
year and if in the new year you're
looking to up your science game I'd
recommend checking out the sponsor of
this video brilliant org it's a website
where you learn different subjects like
physics mathematics computer science a
whole bunch more and you learn by
actively solving problems which is the
best if not the only way to properly
learn a subject the questions are built
around problems that you have to solve I
really enjoy solving them myself
especially the weekly problem is it
keeps my mind fresh and also their
proper mathematics or science questions
at your solving so you're actually
learning some real valuable information
so if that sounds of interest check out
brilliant org slash do s there's also a
link in the description below and for
the first 200 people who subscribe
they're giving away a 20% discount for
their annual membership which unlocks
all of their premium content they've got
a lot of stuff on there also for free
so check that out so that's it thanks so
much for watching and I'll see you in
the new year
[Music]
[Music]